crazy I never hear it like this I see  music as scholars and in this case you  can really feel the colors I'm gonna do  it again I was born and raised in  Colombia Colombia is a local general  Feliciano in spiritual the Caloris  that's the way I describe my sound we  got yellow we got pink to reggaeton good  vibrations good good again  green red they could be like more  passion or more sexy purple New York I  want to know you're looking for all my  dreams you just open up my mind there's  a whole world to conquer  we are not making music just for Latinos  we do it for the culture you know we  make music to the world we really want  people to feel the colors hey si que  tenga Capelli hey Peggy my cambia  they carry a mariano ceci romania Molly  Mahajan  [Music]